- [Instructor] In this
video, we're going to see
if we can compute what three
divided by 0.75 is equal to,
and I'll give you a little bit of a hint
before I tell you to pause the video.
So let's imagine three
wholes right over here,
and what if we were to
think of these three wholes,
these three ones, and what if we were to
think about them in terms of hundredths?
Well then we could, once we
express these as hundredths,
we could say, well how many
groups of 75 hundredths
can we divide this into?
How many equal groups of 75 hundredths?
To help you think about that,
here's a little bit of a visualization
where three is divided into
equal groups of 75 hundredths.
So pause this video and use what I have,
this little visual here, as a big hint
to figure out what three
divided by 75/100 is.
All right, now let's do it together.
So as I said, we started with three ones,
or three wholes, however
you want to think about it,
and you could divide division by 75/100
as saying, well how many
equal groups of 75 hundredths
can you divide these three wholes into?
And so we thought about these three wholes
in terms of hundredths, and
the way it's been color coded,
it actually has already been divided
into four equal groups of 75 hundredths.
You can count these, so this is
10, 20, 30, 40,
50, 60, 70,
and then five hundredths.
So this right over here, this
is one group of 75 hundredths.
Then in green you have another
group of 75 hundredths.
So you have 10, 20, 30,
40, 50, 60, 70,
and then 75, so that right over,
let me use a color I can see.
This right over here is our second group.
This is our first group right over there.
Then that's our third group,
these are all equal
groups of 75 hundredths,
and that's our fourth equal group
of 75 hundredths in the green again.
So how many equal groups of 75 hundredths
can you divide three wholes into?
Well, clearly it is equal to four.